didier sapy directeur de la fédération
nationale avenir et qualité de vie à des
personnes âgées
bonsoir à didier sapy merci d'être avec
nous ce soir sur arte france alors on
lisait 400 millions d'euros dès l'année
prochaine pour le plan à grand âge du
gouvernement déjà comment vous
accueillez vous accueillez des annonces
du premier ministre
bonsoir bien écoutez nous sommes un
petit peu partagé en réalité non c'est
pas forcément toujours une question une
question d'argent c'est aussi une
question de vision du secteur et et de
mesures structurelles pour accompagner
les difficultés
auxquelles font face nos membres il ya
des points positifs dans les annonces du
premier ministre notamment sur sur la
question de l'aide à domicile
les augmentations de salaires qui avait
déjà été annoncé par la ministre
brigitte bourguignon et l'instauration
d'un tarif plancher de leur des à
domicile ça c'est une mesure qui est
importante parce qu'effectivement il y
avait des grosses disparités entre les
départements qui gère pas tous de la
même manière cette cette question là
malheureusement à 22 euros je crains que
ce soit un petit peu faible malgré tout
parce que ça n'a peut-être pas justement
cette augmentation de 15 % des salaires
alors que la réalité des cours dans
l'est la domitienne se situerait plutôt
aujourd'hui avant l'augmentation de
salaire à 24 euros
alors quel est l'état aujourd'hui des
ehpad du secteur en général
dans le secteur des ehpad la grande
difficulté est effectivement en termes
de ressources humaines la réponse
qu'apporte le premier ministre n est pas
du tout pas du tout à la hauteur des
attentes aujourd'hui la question n'est
pas de créer dix mille postes
d'aides-soignants dans les cinq ans qui
viennent sachant qu'en plus la réalité
c'est qu'ils nous en faudrait 350 milles
et pas dix mille donc oui on est très
très loin très très loin du compte mais
là il s'agit de 10000 postes
supplémentaires
alors qu'aujourd'hui les postes qui sont
déjà financés dans le secteur sont pas
pourvus on a beaucoup de mal à trouver
des aides soignants et aujourd'hui au
contraire il faudrait que dans une
mesure urgente le plfss puisse prévoir
de renforcer les équipes dans les
établissements de pouvoir nous permettre
aux aides-soignants d'être soulagé et
d'avoir plus de temps pour effectuer
leur travail dans meilleures conditions
en recrutant d'autres catégories de
personnel pour venir les aider
aujourd'hui on peut recruter massivement
dans le secteur à très court terme
former des professionnels et améliorer
les conditions de travail de ceux qui
sont encore là alors on parlait aussi
d'un tarif un plancher nationale qui
doit être mise en place à 22 euros de
l'heure pour les aides à domicile les
écarts pratiqué jusqu'ici entre autres
départements étaient étaient vraiment
trop grand c'était nécessaire
d'harmoniser un peu tout ça
merci même pas une question d'harmonie
d'harmonisation c'est une question de
solvabilisation par l'état des
défaillances de certains départements on
aurait effectivement on avait encore des
départements qui étaient à 17 18 19
euros de l'heure comme alors que comme
je vous le disais le coût réel d'une
heure d'aidé à domicile se situe plutôt
aux alentours de 24 euros donc on est
très loin du compte malheureusement
c'est l'état et la sécurité sociale ce
qui est presque une anomalie par rapport
à l'organisation et à la gouvernance du
secteur c'est l'état qui va devoir
pallier les insuffisances de certains
départements et émettre des moyens par
rapport à ça est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
sentez un peu les les oubliés j'ai envie
de dire du quinquennat d'emmanuel macron
pas du tout donc je je ne sens pas les
oubliés du quinquennat parce que sur le
quinquennat beaucoup de choses ont été
faites il ya eu le ségur il ya eu
beaucoup d'avancées pour le secteur
malheureusement il y avait il y avait
beaucoup de beaucoup de retard en
revanche la grande déception et c'est
pas le fait d'être des oubliés du
quinquennat mais la grande déception
c'est effectivement le fait qu' on n'est
pas sept 7 grandes lois structurelles
pour le secteur qui nous permettrait de
transformer et de faire évoluer vraiment
sensiblement qualitativement nos
organisations
c'est une grande loi qui avait été
promise par le président macron qui dans
le gouvernement a annoncé qu'elle serait
pas qu'elle serait pas présenté au
parlement avant la fin de la législature
donc c'est et on voit bien qu'avec eux
mêmes malgré ce que nous disait le
gouvernement sur le fait que le plf le
plfss
intégrerait des des mesures
structurelles pour le secteur ce ne sont
pas des mesures structurelles loin de là
et on fait pas un projet de société avec
un projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale donc la réalité c'est
qu'on a vraiment besoin d'une loi d'une
loi de programmation pluriannuelle et
qu'on espère bien que ce sera au coeur
de la prochaine présidentielle merci
beaucoup didier sapy d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir sur arte france rappelle
que vous êtes là directeur de la
fédération nationale avenir et qualité
de vie des personnes âgées merci
beaucoup